SEAN HANNITY TAKES THE REINS
WERE NOT FROM NEW YORK CITY.
>> Sean: ONE SWAMP TO THE
OTHER PAIRED WELCOME TO
"HANNITY."
TODAY IS DAY 35 OF THE DEMOCRATS
SECRET SOVIET STYLE IMPEACHMENT
COUP ATTEMPTS.
ALTHOUGH IT'S REALLY BEEN OUR
GOAL, THINK ABOUT IT, FROM THE
DAY THAT YOU COME UP WE THE
PEOPLE, ELECTED DONALD TRUMP AS
PRESIDENT.
BREAKING JUST MOMENTS AGO, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY MAY BE STARTING
TO INFECTION AT LEAST ONE
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESS WOMAN NOW
REPORTING TO OPPOSE THE PARTIES
LATEST UNFAIR IMPEACHMENT
MEASURE.
WE WILL HAVE A FULL REPORT
TONIGHT FROM CAPITOL HILL BUT
FIRST, ANOTHER DAY, SECRET
MEETING, SECRET HEARING, SECRET
TRANSCRIPTS, SECRET
WHISTLE-BLOWER IN ON
WHISTLE-BLOWER, HERE'S A
WHISTLE-BLOWER, ALL BECAUSE OF A
PHONE CALL BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE.
TONIGHT, LET ME JUST CUT TO THE
CHASE HERE.
NONE OF THIS REALLY IN TRUTH
MATTERS.
THE FAKE WHISTLE-BLOWERS
THOUGHTS, THEIR FEELINGS, THEY
DON'T MATTER.
ANONYMOUS SOURCES DON'T MATTER.
WITNESSES TO THE PHONE CALL,
THEY DON'T MATTER.
NONE OF THIS CIRCUS BUT
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW DRAGGING THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY THROUGH MATTERS
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE ACTUAL
TRANSCRIPT.
IT IS PUBLIC AND IT SHOWS ZERO,
NINE, NO MISCONDUCT WHATSOEVER
BY THE PRESIDENT.
THE TRANSCRIPT NOT ONLY
EXONERATES THE PRESIDENT BUT IT
CLEARLY FEATURES A PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES UPHOLDING HIS
SWORN DUTY TO EXECUTE THE LAWS
OF THE UNITED STATES AND
INVESTIGATE FOREIGN ELECTION
INTERFERENCE SO NOTHING THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE SUPPOSEDLY CARED
ABOUT FOR THREE YEARS ALL OF A
SUDDEN MATTERS.
BY THE WAY, THERE WAS EVEN A
COURT DECISION IN UKRAINE AND
THAT FOUND THAT THEIR GOVERNMENT
INTERFERED IN OUR 2016 ELECTIONS
AND AN EFFORT TO HELP HILLARY
RODHAM CLINTON.
I THOUGHT DEMOCRATS CARED ABOUT
FOREIGN INTERFERENCE IN OUR
ELECTIONS.
ACCORDING TO A VERY CREDIBLE
REPORT FROM POLITICO,
JANUARY 11, 2017, THEY WENT INTO
SPECIFICITY AND DETAIL ABOUT HOW
UKRAINE WORKED IN CONCERT WITH
THE DNC IN 2016 JUST MERE
DONALD TRUMP AND HELP ELECT
HILLARY CLINTON.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE DNC
LITERALLY COLLUDED WITH UKRAINE.
HOW IRONIC.
TO HELP CLINTON WIN AND TO HER
DONALD TRUMP.
ASKING A COUNTRY, IN THIS CASE
FROM UKRAINE, TO COOPERATE IN AN
INVESTIGATION, THAT'S ACTUALLY
NOT A CRIME.
IT'S NOT BRIBERY, NOT A
MISDEMEANOR, CERTAINLY NOT
TREASON.
IT'S ACTUALLY THE PRESIDENT'S
JOB TO FAITHFULLY UPHOLD AND
EXECUTE THE LAWS OF THE LAND.
THAT IS HIS OATH, THAT IS HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATION.
THE LEADER NOW OF THIS NEW
WITCH HUNT, WE HAVE THE CORRUPT,
COMPROMISE, COWARD, CONGENITAL
LIAR, ADAM SCHIFF.
HE WANTS YOU TO BELIEVE
SOMETHING MUCH DIFFERENT.
SCHIFF WON'T COME ON THEIR SHOW
TO DEFEND HIMSELF.
HE HAS ZERO FIDELITY TO TRUTH.
HE IS A PATHETIC LIAR.
ASK FOR THREE YEARS, HE HAS
WORSHIPED AT THE ALTAR OF HIS
IMPEACHMENT LIES.
CONSTANT LIES.
HE'S GOT ALL THE EVIDENCE WE
WOULD EVER NEED ABOUT RUSSIA
RUSSIA RUSSIA COLLUSION.
IT WAS A HOAX AND CONSPIRACY,
LIES, DIDN'T WORK OUT.
UKRAINE.
IT'S EVOLVING NARRATIVES AND IN
OTHER WORDS, YOU HAVE THE
COWARDLY SCHIFF TRYING REALLY
HARD TO GET HIS LIES STRAIGHT.
REMEMBER, FIRST ACCORDING TO
SCHIFF, THERE WERE MULTIPLE
DIRECT QUID PRO QUO'S FROM THE
PRESIDENT'S CALL WITH YOUR
GRADING AND PRESIDENT AND THEN
THE PRESIDENT RELEASED THE
TRANSCRIPT.
THAT PROVED TO BE A LIE AS WELL.
WHEN UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT AND
THEIR FOREIGN MINISTER BOTH SAID
THEY FELT ZERO PRESSURE
WHATSOEVER WHAT, THEN THERE IS
SCHIFF, HE CLAIMED IT WAS SOME
KIND OF BEHIND THE SCENES EFFORT
TO SHAKE DOWN UKRAINE OVER TIME
BY WITHHOLDING.
WHAT WE FOUND OUT NO MONEY WAS
ACTUALLY RELEASED WITHOUT ANY
CONDITIONS WHATSOEVER AND THAT
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW THAT THE MONEY WAS
DELAYED AT THE TIME OF THE CALL,
SCHIFF HAD TO CHANGE HIS
NARRATIVE AGAIN, CALLING AND
WITNESS AFTER WITNESS BUT ONLY
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS, WITHOUT
REAL REPUBLICAN DUE PROCESS AT
ALL.
TO SPECULATE ON THE PRESIDENT'S
INTENTIONS.
YOU KNOW WHO HASN'T TESTIFIED?
NOT TALKING ANYMORE ABOUT THE
SO-CALLED WHISTLE-BLOWER
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER.
HE STARTED THE ENTIRE PROCESS.
WHY IS THAT?
SCHIFF'S OFFICE WE NOW KNOW
WASN'T IN CONTACT.
APPARENTLY EVEN ADVISING HIM
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING.
REPUBLICANS, THEY WILL BE ASKING
A LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT
AND LACK OF SUPPORT OF
JOE BIDEN.
THEY TOLD HIM THAT APPARENTLY
ACCORDING TO REPORTS TO GET A
LAWYER.
THEY ENCOURAGED HIM TO FILE A
COMPLAINT WITH THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL AND THAT MEANS
SHIFT IS A BACK WITNESS IN THE
CASE.
HE BLATANTLY LIED ABOUT THE
FOREIGN NATION AS WE HAVE PROVEN
ON TV.
SCHIFF IS COMPROMISED, HE'S A
FACT WITNESS, IN THE CASE IN
WHICH HE IS NOW PRESIDING.
HE SHOULD RECUSE HIMSELF.
HE IS COMPROMISED, CORRUPT, A
COWARD, A CONGENITAL LIAR.
HE'S ALSO LEADING THE NEW
WITCH HUNT HERE TODAY WHEN
DEMOCRATS SAID THEY WERE ALARMED
BY THE TESTIMONY OF ALEXANDER
VAN MITTON, NATIONAL SECURITY
EXPERT, I UNDERSTAND A WAR HERO,
THANK YOU SORRY FOR SERVING OUR
COUNTRY, HE WAS ON THE PHONE
CALL, THE PROBLEM IS, KEEP IN
MIND, THE DEMOCRATS
INTERPRETATION OF HIS
INTERPRETATION OF THE PHONE
CALL.
WE DON'T NEED HIS INTERPRETATION
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE TRANSCRIPT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER, FRANKLY, WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT, I MEAN THAT
SINCERELY, WHAT HE OR ANYBODY
ELSE THINKS.
IT'S ALL FAMED OUTRAGE.
WHILE NOT GOOD SOMEBODY ELSE
INTERPRETED IT THE SICK WAY WE
DO OR THE CORRUPT WAY WE DO.
OKAY.
WELL THAT'S THEIR INTERPRETATION
BUT IT'S A MATTER OF LAW EVEN
THE DEPARTMENT OF INJUSTICE
INVESTIGATION CONCLUDED TODAY,
NO CONCLUSION.
THERE WAS NOTHING WRONG, NOTHING
ILLEGAL ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S
CALL.
BUT THE CORRECT DEMOCRATS, THEY
COULD NOT CARE LESS.
ADAM SCHIFF ADAM SCHIFF, PELOSI,
THEY ARE NOT READY FOR PHASE TWO
OF THEIR IMPEACHMENT COUP
ATTEMPT.
TODAY THEY COOKED UP A
RESOLUTION, I HAVE IT RIGHT HERE
IN FRONT OF ME, IT'S NOT WORTH
THE PAPER THAT IS PRINTED ON
TRADE I WASTED PAPER.
I HURT TREES IN THE PROCESS.
THAT WOULD MAKE THEIR COUP
PROCEEDINGS PUBLIC HAD ONE BIG
CATCH.
WHEN YOU ACTUALLY READ THE
DOCUMENT, WHICH I HAVE DONE,
THERE IS ONE HUGE MASSIVE
GIGANTIC CAVEAT THAT THE
COMPROMISE CONGENITAL LIAR
ADAM SCHIFF AND FELLOW
DEMOCRATS, THEY ACTUALLY CAN
VETO ANY REPUBLICAN ATTEMPTS TO
CALL WITNESSES, SUBPOENA
EVIDENCE, AND PRETTY MUCH
ANYTHING ELSE.
THEY NEED THE COMPROMISE B6'S
APPROVAL FOR EVERYTHING AND
MAYBE THAT'S WHY NANCY PELOSI IS
REFUSING TO CALL THIS
UNIMPEACHABLE STOMACH OFFICIAL
IMPEACHMENT RESOLUTION.
>> HAVE YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
IMPEACHMENT RESOLUTION?
STICKER IT'S ON AN IMPEACHMENT
RESOLUTION.
>> Sean: I GUESS PELOSI AND I
CAN AGREE ON ONE THING.
IT'S NOT AN IMPEACHMENT
RESOLUTION FOR THIS IS NOT WHAT
NEWT GINGRICH OFFERED
BILL CLINTON IN 1998.
HIS PROCESS WAS ACTUALLY REALLY
FAIR.
SHE DOESN'T WANT TO MIRROR THAT.
WHAT THIS IS A SMOKE AND
MIRRORS.
THEY ARE TRYING TO MAKE YOU
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT IT IS
NOT THAT IT IS NOT FAIR.
IT IS NOT WHAT NEWT GINGRICH
OFFERED TO CLINTON.
IT'S ANYTHING BUT FAIR.
WHAT IS REALLY A'S IS A MASSIVE
FISHING EXPEDITION IN THE HOPES
THAT ANY COOKTOP ALLEGATION
MIGHT STICK.
THEN WE WILL IMPEACH HIM.
WE DON'T KNOW ON WHAT BUT WE
WILL IMPEACH HIM THEN.
IT IS A FRAUDULENT, IT IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, SHOW TRIAL,
DEVOID OF ALL DUE PROCESS.
IT IS A LEGITIMATE, IT IS AN
IMPEACHMENT COUP ATTEMPT RUN BY
A CORRUPT COMPROMISE CONGENITAL
LIAR WHO HAS BEEN HELL-BENT ON
DESTROYING THE PRESIDENCY OF
DONALD TRUMP REGARDLESS OF
TRUTH, LOGIC, COMMON SENSE,
REASON, AND FAX.
BREAKING JUST MOMENTS AGO, AT
LEAST ONE DEMOCRAT APPARENTLY IS
BREAKING RANKS.
NBC NEWS REPORTING THAT
NEW JERSEY CONGRESSMAN JEFF
VAN DREW WILL LIKELY VOTE